مزيد من التفاصيل سيدلي بها بعد حوالي ربع
ساعه من الان مدعي عام الجمهوريه الذي
سيعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا في مدينه انسي وهي
مدينه تقع في جبال الالب الفرنسيه ليس
بعيدا عن الحدود مع سويسرا وهي المدينه
التي شهدت هذا الاعتداء الدامي في احدى
حدائقها التي كانت تكتظ بعدد لا يحصى من
السياح كما قال شهود عيان عند الساعه
التاسعه والدقيقه الاربعين بالتوقيت
المحلي هنا في فرنسا قفز هذا المعتدي نحو
مدخل الحديقه وهو يصرخ قال كلاما قليلا
غير مفهوم وانقض بسلاح ابيض كان يحمله
سكين تحديدا انقض به على اطفال كانوا داخل
عرباتهم داخل عربات الاطفال يعني
كما تسمى بالفرنسيه على عرباتهم راح
يطعنهم الواحد تلو الاخر فاصيب اربعه
اطفال بجراح جراحهم خطره واثنان من هؤلاء
الاطفال الذين تقل اعمارهم جميعا عن
الثلاث سنوات اثنان منهم حياتهم بخطر شديد
هم الان بين الحياه والموت كما جرح شخصان
اخران العدد الاجمالي للجرحى هو سته
المعتدي كان حصل على وضعيه لاجئ في السويد
في شهر ابريل نيسان اي قبل حوالي شهر ونصف
وكان الطلبه في شهر نوفمبر من العام
الماضي عام 2022 ان يحصل على وضعيه لاجئ
هنا في فرنسا من المكتب الفرنسي لحمايه
اللاجئين لكنه لم يحصل على هذه الوضعيه
وضعيه اللاجئ في فرنسا الشرطه الفرنسيه
كما نقلت عنها وسائل اعلام كثيره قالت ان
المعتدي يبلغ من العمر 32 عاما وهو يحمل
بطاقه
سوري طبعا هذا ما تشير اليه البطاقه لكن
التحقيق يتركز الان حول ما اذا كانت هذه
البطاقه عائده فعلا للشخص الذي ارتكب
الاعتداء يدعى يعني اسمه الاول عبد المسيح
كما تقول مصادر الشرطه وهو دخل الى فرنسا
مؤخرا بطريقه قانونيه طبعا بعد حصوله على
وضعيه اللاجئ في السويد فاطمه الرئيس
ماكرون وصف الاعتداء الجباء وصف الاعتداء
بانه جبان الى اقصى حدود وان كل الامه تحت
هذه الصدمه رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه
اليزابيث بورن ووزير الداخليه جيرال دغمنا
يصلان بعد قليل الى انسي واقسى اليمين
واقصى اليسار اللذان يختلفان سياسيا عاده
اتفقا على وصف هذا الهجوم بالمروع